Karl Lagerfeld in one of his final
public appearances last November the
star of Paris's Christmas lights
ceremony Fame that he gained over a
lifetime of pioneering in the world of
fashion it takes something special to
stand out enter the legend of Lagerfeld
at the Chanel flagship store in the
French capital they miss him already
eternal admiration reads one tribute at
London Fashion Week the Duchess of
Cornwall joined others in paying her
respects to fashion royalty outside too
his presence is everywhere and thoughts
about what his death will mean for
Chanel we will miss him
keep it keep it classic yeah can we
close it as we wore the classic Chanel
yeah keep it classic yeah don't be like
a next streak stylepro please you know
really sad news for this it's already
close friends and family a new Benetton
the struggling Italian brand that could
do with Lagerfeld's Midas touch
remembered him too as they showed off
their latest collection yes I will keep
very close to my heart as the example of
a man who knew how to be an
extraordinary artistic director he is
the father of all artistic directors
many will try but few will leave a
legacy like Karl Lagerfeld and for more
on Karl Lagerfeld's legacy and vey
pleased to welcome a yet Europe she
herself is a fashion and jewelry
designer welcome yet AOPA you met Karl
Lagerfeld many times what are your
personal recollections of the man the
last time I met him was at his show that
he had of his pictures that he took of
scat for the car company open and nobody
could sort of show himself as
flamboyantly as he did you know when he
was around you felt like the king of
everything is in the room and there was
like a whisper around him Carla said
cars there and the hole in tirage you
know trying to make sure that he was
happy and he was a very very intelligent
sharp man he flamboyant is a good way to
describe him that is his public image
but how different was his public image
from the man you met in private if you
think about his roots back in good old
Hamburg you know Hamburg is a very
conservative and Industry City and he
came from quite a wealthy home and he
seemed to have been what today would be
called an RDS child he wanted to draw
all the time he didn't want to play with
other kids so you see that sometimes you
should leave very creative people alone
and not make them change otherwise
before we won't have another
calligrapher one day so he was always
seeking attention he always wanted to be
in the public eyes what you're saying
yeah but I believe he was probably much
more intelligent that he ever showed you
know because he was reading all the time
he spoke several languages and one time
he said that he was speaking way faster
than his brain was sort of formulating
the words so sometimes the stuff he said
was very very provocative like in
contraband yeah sometimes he didn't like
fat people they didn't like old people
that he didn't like this and that and
you know because he was such an amazing
creative mind he was allowed to do that
imagine somebody else would do that
today now you know you yourself are a
famous fashion designer what do you
think made Karl Lagerfeld's fashions so
unique well he had this amazing sense of
how he could sort of keep this branch
and now totally mm up to snuff totally
modern and fresh so he invited young
talents all the time to be on stage and
to wear his creations so there was an
edge to the brand that kept it very
young and fresh because if you imagine
how all the brand is now old Kellogg
effete was and how much everybody is
still desiring these bags that's really
a fabulous thing he did in apart from is
fashion he was such an amazing
personality everybody felt that they
knew him but apparently in private he
was a very quiet and reclusive man well
obviously if you know a lot about the
world and especially a lot about the
fashion industry it maybe makes you want
to be alone sometimes because if you
have to do if you have to deal with
vanities all the time you may be
sometimes also deal was not only the
good part in people but also with the
vain difficult part so it's very clear
that for an artist you maybe then want
to be reclusive alone and in peace and
he had very close friends with Monte
Carlo but I guess felt at home very much
there will never be anybody like him
again gosh there's so many anecdotes
about him people talk about what he said
what he did what is your favorite
recollection of can Lagerfeld well I
like the way he was sort of controlling
this whole industry and how he was sort
of making bad jokes at the same time he
was sort of dissing everybody but making
everybody fall in love with him at the
same time yes as you said he was
controversial he once described a French
president as an embassy but I think
that's people loved his car was amazing
yeah yeah oh thank you so much fun to do
job you and sharing your thoughts with
thanks a lot